to everyone who's watching this other
than once he is exactly the guy he think
he is another a lot of people in the
internet you know to kind of think and
and I know people have accused mark
before of you know his reactions are
insincere he yells just to be ridiculous
but do you exactly the guy that it seems
like yes for years it's just so great to
see people finally appreciate what I've
always like I said I'm not surprised at
all the years being successful you're
having so much exactly this but I just
can't believe I get to be a part of it
and I hope it keeps going
oh man um if if you guys have no idea
what's going on right now um I just
watched my well not mine
um a thank you video from my fans from
you guys in it was um it's it's it is
probably the greatest present I've ever
gotten
I don't know I was gonna do something
for I was gonna do something for twenty
thousand subscribers I was gonna and um
now nothing nothing could ever like
compare to that
so thank you thank you all um really
truly honestly thank you um I'll be
right back okay I'm back now oh man
click click the annotation they've been
up there since the beginning to click
them to watch the video watch the video
first before anything else happens it's
just it's absolutely unreal it it
completely blew me away I had no idea
that it was um anyone who's doing it
nighttime I'm flabbergasted at the
number of people that were involved in
it and how the hell you kept it from me
the entire time it's um it's just I
can't believe it it's the most it's the
most amazing thing that I've ever gotten
ever it's it's absolutely incredible and
I'm just I'm absolutely grateful every
day that I get to do this that I get to
get up and entertain you guys and I
I can't you know I didn't know if I was
conveying that well enough to you guys
that it's the greatest feeling in the
world but it's true and you do
understand and and and I I want to get I
want to give back I want to give back so
um I said drunkenly in the video before
I thought that if you guys wanted to do
another giveaway so I think given that
we just launched the t-shirt store um I
I want to give away some t-shirts I
think you guys would like that uh uh I'm
not sure I just want to give away
something I haven't plan anything no but
everything that I had just throw it out
the window
um oh man it's just that's absolutely
incredible you guys are you guys are
beyond the greatest fan of the world I
could not ask for anyone anymore because
I know with it you know the channel is
small hmm the channel is small it's not
that big but I know that bigger channels
don't get this from their fans they
don't do this I know they don't I know
they don't and um and I never want to
take advantage of that I never ever ever
ever do
because I always know that I'm nothing
without you guys as much as you think
you help I help you you help me ten
times more you you inspire me to do more
and so what we're gonna do um only give
away 10 t-shirts just the same thing is
the last time all you got to do is
actually um let's put more rules on it
because I don't want things to go out of
control and I don't want people to feel
like I'm just trying to get things um
the way goes is pick one reaction
compilation to any of them you know it
doesn't matter which one just one we're
gonna do one per person that way there's
more even chance for people to win and
just share it once on Facebook and
Twitter and take a screenshot of it and
then just send me an email of it that's
um that'll be your quote unquote entry
into the raffle and stuff like that um
you can do justjust just do one you know
I'm not asking for a like like last time
I don't want that that was out of
control and it seemed like I was just
mooching for shares I don't want it to
be like that just just once you know to
pick any reaction compilation just share
once on Facebook Twitter take a
screenshot of it I'll send it to me at
the email address right here markiplier
at gmail.com and I'll put your name in a
bucket and all will do the drawing a
week from now and I'll give away ten
shirts I'll take care of shipping
everything cost shirts I don't matter
I'll get in touch with you you give me
your size
I'll buy the shirts I'll send it your
way they may take a bit but I'll get it
to you because
I oh man oh man I can't I can't believe
it
just can't it's the greatest feeling the
world I just donated blood today two of
so I was happy I was like I just
I don't know I just told [ __ ] on it
it's everything here is Bill but yeah
so thank you and
I'm looking forward to the future I am
it's gonna be great so please watch the
video it's going to be up here it's
going to be in the description I'm gonna
hopefully get a video response for it
just thank you guys so much I can't
thank you enough but thank you and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye